In this video, I will show you our
proprietary trading model that I built
after years and years of research. This
study use granular order flow data to
spot where volume is effortlessly moving
price. Hence, where is the path of least
resistance? I use this edge as part of
my daily trading routine and I've done
extensive quantitative validation around
it. I will show you how to use it and
contextualize with deep trades to take
the highest probability areas. As a part
of my contribution to the deep charts
research and development program, I
worked in the role of alpha research to
make it available exclusively on deep
charts. And now, let's go through the
deep effort together and understand the
logic behind how it works and why this
is an amazing
tool to get more precise using order
flow. I come from a study called volume
spread analysis, the VSA. I started this
study when I was using vertical volume
to refine the area of confirmation using
the relationship between volume and
result of price. If I have a wall of
orders here and I have the price
striking here with a lot of volume, I
see that there is no result, so no
follow through of all this effort and
the effort is going on. This one for me
becomes an area, becomes a potential
point of reversal, becomes a level that
I wants to notice. At the same time, if
I see the market doing an amazing
movement with really low efforts, okay,
on the buy side and I see buyers
interacting really aggressively to break
this level and then I see low effort to
make an amazing result. What the market
is telling me? That the balance between
forces here change. And now the path of
least resistance is on the buy side.
It's like a traffic light gives me areas
and gives me situation where the edge is
on my side in a specific moment of the
chart. And the logic behind it was built
is because when you use volume analysis,
for example, you can get into
consolidation area and you can try to
execute multiple times taking a lot of
break even. So, the logic behind was I
only want levels where everything is
telling me that one side is more
aggressive than the other. So, having an
a directional edge and a specific area
edge, so I can have a clear stop loss in
the direction of the model. For example,
you can pair this with the statistical
model of IVB. Now, all this logic behind
that you can use here is based on one
simple order flow concept. And this
concept is the law of effort and result.
And this is really important because you
need to understand that volume and price
gives you two different information. The
volume is telling you how many orders
are entering. The result is telling you
how much these orders are having an
impact in price movement. So, if we are
here, for example, on this floor and we
see aggressive market participants
striking on this level with a huge
volume. And we see that every time the
maximum they can do is printing weak. I
will not consider a continuation because
I see that this level getting really
interesting from a passive participants
perspective. They are keeping all these
orders, okay, they are absorbing here.
This is a usual pattern of a absorption.
And this one comes also from the volume
spread analysis. So, you are not
considering only one side, only the
price, but you are taking also into
consideration the volume. At the same
time, on the other way, when we see
aggression of the buyers and at the same
candle aggression of the sellers, and we
see that the sellers are completely
absorbed and the buyers are rewarded,
what the market is telling us here is
that in this battle they have maybe the
same effort, but the result it's heavy
skew on the upside. So, what I can do as
an analyst, I can understand that the
probability that we continue higher, so
we go to tap into this high is the
biggest one, but the effort is the same.
Maybe you have the same effort from
aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers, but the sellers are completely
absorbed. So, we need to put this and to
frame this into one single law, the law
of effort and results. And the step that
we did later was, how can we make sure
that this
it's transferred into one script and
that is taking into consideration
everything. And after this study came
out, the logic of putting in
relationship price, volume and putting
also in relationship the granularity of
the order inside. And on this we have a
proprietary model that is capable of
filtering all the noise and is giving
you what I like to call triggers,
triggers to potentially execute. And
it's giving you an edge when you have,
for example, frame your area, your point
of interest maybe using price action,
using everything, and you approach the
level back again here and you have your
deep effort telling you, "Look that from
this moment we are askew on the
downside. So, you have your area. And
what this is telling you that the
probability from this box on is to
continue lower. And this can be amazing
also for profit taking because when you
see a an opposite area on the buy side,
you can understand that now this selling
pressure it's almost exhausted and the
probability instead of continuing that
you will go up to this level it's
higher. So, the consideration that you
can make is that it's not worth to risk
all this profit that I make just to make
an additional small movement by risking
all this profit. So, I take it out my
position. What I do? I consider putting
stop below. So, if the market wants to
continue, I'm into the position again. I
took profit on the first one and I have
my liquidation here. This is a smart way
of managing trades. Now, let's go to the
chart and let's understand together how
the deep effort it's giving you an edge.
We are in Nasdaq on this week and we
will see some session where you have a
consolidation phase, some session when
you have a directional phase and we will
understand how much this is powerful
when paired with logic of regression and
logic of bias of the day. So, the bias
for the 26 and the bias for 27 was long.
So, I had a clear bias for the day and
for this I use profile framing. So, all
the short setup if I have a bias, I'm
not interested into taking, okay? So, I
can save the counter trend setups.
Amazing. As you can see, it start giving
you areas where the buying pressure is
dominant. From this, we have an overlap
of two cluster here. This one is the
first area that the model identify
aligned with the long term. So, you can
build from here the first positions as a
trigger in direction of the overall
trend. Now, not all the days will be so
directional, so it's smarter to have
multiple profit targets. One position
you take out, for example, at 50% of the
full profit, and the other one you leave
a runner. The second area that gave us
is this one. This one it's a momentum
setup. Why momentum setup? Because it
closed above it and never test. So, this
one you couldn't take because the market
don't give you a test. Here it gives you
an area, immediately test, gives you
another area, immediately test, so you
could make a lot of trades on this one.
Then you have a small stop loss here
because even if you are right on the
direction, if you want to be precise,
you need to accept some stop loss. So,
if we go to count it, we have Let's not
consider the full take profit. Let's
consider one to three. You have three R
here. This one it's unfulfilled. You
have minus one R here. Okay. You have
another unfulfilled. Okay. You have a
stop loss here. So, you have minus R.
And finally, the market comes back to
your area. Okay. So, you have an entry
point here because this is a virgin
area, and the market immediately
confirmed this with another area that
unfortunately it's unfulfilled. So,
let's consider this small cluster of
setups. You took six R of profit, okay,
three and three, and you lost two. You
are four R positive just by taking
setups in line with the direction bias
of the day with profile framing. Now,
also this day, as I explained to you, I
was long in in bias from profile
framing. So, the volume profile is
telling me that the pressure is building
on the upside. So, I don't take short
even if this were would have been one to
2.5, one to three, all take profit, I
don't consider them. I start to consider
the market from this one. And as you can
see, this area it's amazing because it
give me exactly the pressure. What's
unfortunate here that these two setups
are unfulfilled because the market is so
aggressive that it's not back really
high. The first setup that I will be
able to take is the test of this virgin
area. This one would have been an
amazing one to three risk to reward and
you close the day with only these
setups. So, you need to take into
consideration that there will be days
where you don't have any setups, okay?
Also, for this day here, I am long in
bias, okay? So, when we open the New
York session here, okay? I have one
setup that it's some filled,
unfortunately, here and then I have
another setup that it's filled. So, I
have one stop loss in this area and then
the market break the structure. This is
the beginning of the range. So, when it
breaks on the opposite side using the
deep effort, I don't go trend counter
trend on this one. So, I need to wait
that we have another confirmation of
directional. But, unfortunately, this
day we never go back to this level till
late in the session. Look how much this
would have been amazing with these
setups. What's the problem that we are
late in the night, okay? This would have
been like six take profit at once, but
this was not viable for me because we
broke below the initial balance and as
you know, I like to pair the NASDAQ
effort with the IVB model. So, you need
to keep in mind a profile framing or IVB
directional bias paired with the deep
effort to give you a confirmation. I
want to show you this setup even if
these one are not executed cuz I want to
show you how the market is not
identifying momentum candle, but it's
identifying for you areas that are
potential strong point retest. This one
have been retested perfectly. This one
have been retested perfectly. And in
situation of long momentum, it's not so
difficult to take amazing risk to reward
by covering below the areas, okay?
Unfortunately, when they are outside the
timing or counter trend in respect to
the bias, we don't take it. This is was
the night. I hope you enjoyed the video.
See you on the next one.